cutting through the dark one of hundreds
of meteors peppering our skies here in
Port and cross in Scotland to this one
caught on camera in hemel hempstead they
were spotted by stargazers across the UK
in kenly near croydon they SAT patiently
watching hoping to see one I think
everybody's basically interested in
astronomy people that come here that are
brand new always love to have a look
through the telescope and see things
like Saturn and Jupiter I think
everybody's got a fundamental interest
in what's what's up there the phenomenon
happens once a year when the Earth's
orbit around the Sun reaches a certain
point it always occurs between mid-july
and late August the Earth spins through
the cosmic dust less from the tail of a
comet swift-tuttle which passed through
in 1992 the particles collide with our
upper atmosphere at speeds of 36 miles
per second and on hitting the atmosphere
they vaporize into flashes of light
which is what we can see down on the
ground oh it's a good opportunity to see
lots of meteorites especially this year
is there's no moon it's a nice clear sky
so easily you could blink and miss it so
some hedge their bets with telescopes
while others carefully scan the sky the
bright of the meteor the rarer it is but
for everyone we manage to spot coming
through our atmosphere there are several
others which are too dull for us to see
with experts predicting up to a hundred
of these could enter our atmosphere
every hour for some lucky star gazers
space may have put on quite a show
cheval Robbins Sky News